se mobiliser merci la parole est à
monsieur christophe priou merci monsieur
le président ma question concerne le
sempiternel dossier de notre dame des
landes
monsieur le premier ministre votre
prédécesseur manuel valls elle concerne
aussi jean marc ayrault a promis une
évacuation de la zad à l'automne 2016
mais l'automne est déjà loin il ne s'est
rien passé ce tri strictement rien n'a
changé sur le terrain du non droit
quand allez-vous respecter la parole
publique et les habitants de la
loire-atlantique favorable au transfert
merci de respecter la voix du peuple qui
s'est exprimé en faveur du projet par
référendum en juin 2016 référendum
proposé par le président de la
république
les arrêtés préfectoraux relatifs au
chantier de l'aéroport sont
définitivement validé et pourtant c'est
l'enlisement
après cinq années d'immobilisme des
propriétaires demandent des
rétrocessions de plus la préparation des
mesures réglementaires notamment sur les
compensations environnementales
nécessite de reprendre des arts et des
modificatif le droit bafoué la
crédibilité de la parole publique est
sérieusement entamée
les manifestations qui dégénèrent encore
ces derniers jours exaspère les français
bien entendu nous en avons largement
fait les frais à nantes et à rennes à de
multiples reprises sur ce dossier et les
français ils attendent un positionnement
clair du gouvernement notamment
l'évacuation de la zad parce que rien ne
peut se faire avant plus l'intervention
est repoussé plus le volet judiciaire
liée aux expulsions sera délicat à gérer
le président la république et vous même
avez dit que les jours les semaines et
les mois qui nous séparent de la fin du
culte de ce quinquennat serait utile
alors prouvez le sans jouer la montre
avez vous l'intention d'agir si oui
quand sinon dit le franchement les
français ont le droit de connaître votre
position et où la parole est à monsieur
andré vallini secrétaire d'état chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci monsieur le président pour faire
suite à la réponse à l'instant de jean
marc ayrault sur l'union européenne
disons que la france était à
l'initiative
je veux excuser l'absence de bernard
cazeneuve qui est aujourd'hui justement
à berlin pour répondre à votre question
monsieur le député sur notre dame des
landes
d'abord vous l'avez la légitimité
démocratique de ce projet a été
confortée par le référendum du 26 juin
dernier personne ne le conteste
deuxièmement toutes les procédures ont
été réalisés dans le respect du droit et
tous les recours engagés contre le
projet 169 en tout cent soixante neuf
recours ont abouti à un roger
ce fut notamment le cas en 2000 couple
et ils vous l'avez clarations d'utilité
publique ce fut le cas l'été 2015 avec
le rejet par la cour de cassation du
pourvoi contre les ordres
d'expropriations et encore le 14
novembre dernier lorsque la cour
administrative d'appel de nantes a
validé les arrêtés préfectoraux
permettant de démarrer le chantier de
l'aéroport
mesdames et messieurs les députés de
l'opposition nous sommes en discussion
avec la commission européenne sur un pré
contentieux concernant notamment le scot
de la région de nantes dès que nous
aurons obtenu le feu vert de la
commission européenne le projet sera
poursuivi et il faudra réussir
l'évacuation du site
une évacuation qui demandera beaucoup de
forces de l'ordre qu'il faudra engager
dans la durée l'évacuation de la zad
permettra d'engager les travaux
préliminaires archéologie préventive
déboisement compensation
environnementale puis nous engagerons le
gouvernement engagera les travaux
principaux enfin je vous indique pour
vous rassurer définitivement que le
gouvernement va engager le processus
écoutez bien nous allons engager le
processus de prorogation de la
déclaration d'utilité publique qui vient
à échéance en février 2018
je pense que vous êtes rassuré sur la
volonté de ce gouvernement d'aboutir
dans la réalisation de notre dame des
landes
merci monsieur va